welcome back to new rockstars I'm Eric
Voss and Star Wars arises Skywalker
reportedly its original script draft by
previous director Colin Trevorrow late
then in those flames of those of us who
prefer the fictional universe cannon
that exists in our heads to the one that
Hollywood gives us like what every
thoughts about the rise of Skywalker and
I genuinely side with director JJ Abrams
that it's equally okay to love this film
and to hate it isn't it thrilling to
dance with the devil in the details of
the different film that almost was
deleted scenes rejected concepts the
messy process of drafting a story with
characters that have at most 55 percent
popularity therefore I will break down
this alternate Rivera script for Star
Wars Episode nine for your viewing and
maybe listening pleasure okay here we go
this was initially shared with the world
by a guy by the name of Robert Meyer
Burnett on YouTube his over 2 hour long
YouTube video was broken down into
excerpts that were posted on reddit and
while at first this seemed like one of
these impossible to verify claims sound
like what we saw with the rumor JJ
Abrams cut go watch my breakdown of that
but I won't judge you for wherever you
land on this skepticism spectrum or any
spectrum
okay so reportedly the strap was written
by Colin Trevorrow and Derek Connolly
who were the guys behind the dressing
world movies really talented dudes but
after Trevorrow was announced to direct
Star Wars Episode nine he later parted
ways in September 2017 due to what else
creative differences and some conflicts
of rewrites in the studio ended up
replacing tomorrow in connolly with JJ
Abrams and Chris Terrio and all Ford
these guys have writing credits on the
final version of the film but according
to the source the sraw O'Connell II
draft was finished on December 16 2016
which was a week before Carrie Fisher
passed away and it was titled duel of
the fates honestly pretty sick title the
opening crawl would read as follows the
iron grip of the first order has spread
to the farthest reaches of the galaxy
only a few scattered planets remain
unoccupied traitorous acts are
punishable by death determined to
suffocate a growing unrest Supreme
Leader kylo Ren has silenced all
communication between neighboring
systems led by general Leia Organa the
resistance has planned a secret mission
to prevent their annihilation and forge
a path to freedom
we were then pan down where to kuat's a
core world planet known for its
shipyards that built ships for the
Republic
and later the empire bb-8 and rose dqo
who rumor has it played a bigger role in
this story infiltrates a quat moon where
the first order built their ships using
forced labor blow is cots orbital ring
and another moon where Finn and Poe are
gray joins them she's disguised as a
skin Raider and she has created her own
weapon a double bladed lightsaber
combining her stat and Luke's split
saber with it's cracked Kyber crystal
their mission is to send explosives
along the power shaft that delivers raw
ore to the ring it would cause the chain
reaction explosion but of course
something goes wrong the first order
contains the blast character by the name
of Admiral von calls the resistance
tactics pitiful
Poe then Rey Rose mediates steel an
eclipse class Star Destroyer to escape
then we see a ship called the knife 9
containing the Knights of Ren it arrives
at quwata and a character named
saccharin kills Admiral Bond for his
failure tattoo chorus art collapse from
the vibrant city to a sprawling
dystopian slum new structures are built
atop the old art deco Oedipus's of the
old republic the first order occupies
this planet with a giant palace citadel
citizens are scavengers Hux is now
chancellor lux he addresses visca Cova
the traitor who helped the resistance
steel that Star Destroyer and then
bisque is beheaded with a light blade
guillotine we then learned that the
first order has allies Hux and Commander
select to meet with their warlords
actually similar to the Imperial officer
meeting in a new hope this council wants
to know one thing
where is kylo Ren and Huck's only knows
that kylo sneaking something of great
power and speaking that devil we cut to
Mustafar
kylo is accompanied by a maul type droid
kylos gets double meaning he's been
searching for something for a long time
and going off most double grow time
periods like two weeks and most
interestingly kylo is being hunted by
luke's force ghost Luke says this is
where the dark path leads an empty tomb
kylo responds word of your path lead
Luke tries to convince kylo to return to
Leia but kylo says I'm going to be more
powerful than any Jedi even you and I
got a posse to highlight this my
favorite helmet of the strafes
ghost Luke haunting kylo like
Shakespeare's Banquo haunting in Macbeth
one of my favorite moments when the
final act of
said I was Luke's promised to kylo
strike me down and anger and I'll always
be with you I just would have loved to
see this old Uncle Joe Joe rabbit his
nephew but anyway back to Mustafar kylo
enters Vader's temple there he finds a
Sith holocron revealing a hologram of
Palpatine Palpatine leaves a recording
for Vader with a contingency if Luke
would ever kill the Emperor the Skywalk
gap to their medical system to see tall
vellum master the sea end my teacher and
I loved reading this description after
scanning kylo the holocron explodes and
releases red lightning which burns kylo
who screams it's a true mission
impossible self-destructing message and
I love that it waits until after it lets
him listen to the message to explode
okay next cut to resistance based on
choral off Leia senses what's happening
to her son damn it Ben just dad your
grandfather's porn box and chewy and
conics report the return of the kuat
team landing their massive Star
Destroyer on the planet
Rey uses a mind trick on the first-order
officers that are still on board ray
tells Ben that she doesn't feel
confident in her Jedi training and that
she's been having kylo related
nightmares and that she can't explain
the connection Finn says you have to
shut him out you can't change it's too
late
Rey responds it's never too late to
change you taught me that Finn the
resistance finds first order weaponry on
the story including tanks ties 80s
teased some purple stuff but they don't
have a large enough army to use them
Rey researchers the ancient Jedi texts
that she stole from much to to discover
that under the course on Jedi Temple is
an old old communication system called a
force beacon that can signal 50 planets
so they plan to use his force beacon to
reach out to allies realize the first
order probably couldn't stop the signal
since it predates Imperial Tech and Ray
says hope is all we have left
reigns with horse ghost Luke is trying
to get her stronger in the force while
he tries to push kylo to let out his
inner bin in her band ray asks Luke
Penance the doc suffocates the light the
light extinguishes the dark over and
over and over again how was that balance
in the force and Luke responds I know
that anger my father had it to race
Knights back so says my master and his
masterful him a thousand masters so
eager to tell
how to live and they argue with Rey and
cysteine that she is no one her parents
no one Luke just tries to convince her
that the force is still speaking to her
meanwhile and her Ben kylo returns to
Coruscant space is all [ __ ] up he was
wearing Mandalorian armor that was
melted and fused into his skin
kylo confronts Hux and belittles him
saying he doesn't need titles and that
the power he discovered will make
destroying plants insignificant in the
orders Hux find the resistance wipe them
out leave the girl to me meanwhile the
resistance have split into two groups
Group a has been our two Threepio Andros
had in the course ought to activate that
force beacon meanwhile Rey Poe and
Chewie head to some other planet to find
someone the description here is a bit
vague from the leaker meanwhile Leia
stays home at the base but before ray
leaves she tells Leia that she believes
there is still good in kylo Leia
skeptical and she tells Rey you're not
like my father or my brother you're new
whatever happens remember the force
chose you Ray
your story isn't written by anyone else
as kylo leaves Coruscant
he takes Vader's mask finally
understanding this grandfather you will
love to cloud your judgment
he says burrowing Vader's mask off the
balcony and shattering it now we move on
to Act two now while I'm going through
all this stuff I often have to listen to
clips over and over again to find those
audio clues and I need good headphones
for that but I'm on the go Raik on
wireless earbuds are my weapon a choice
thanks to Ray Khan for sponsoring this
video
ray Conner earbuds started about half
the price of any other premium wireless
earbuds on the market and they sound
just as amazing as the top audio brands
that you're familiar with celebrities
like Snoop Dogg and cardi B love their
rake on earbuds and that's just one of
the many many things I have in common
with cardi B and snoop I have a set of
their latest model the e25 and its
really their best one yet with six hours
of playtime seamless bluetooth pairing
more bass in a more compact design that
gives you a nice noise isolating bit it
also comes in new fun colors I wear
these rake on II 25s while running
errands and they're super comfortable
and they sound great the long battery
life is really helpful when I'm in that
12 items or less checkout line behind
someone with like 59 items I don't get
bad I just keep listening to the Black
Panther soundtrack on my break on a
25-year buds and everything it's okay
and Zen just go to buy rake on Comm
slash new rock star
for 15% off your order or click on the
link in the description below
okay back to the second act of Trevorrow
and Connolly's duel of the fates script
the first order tracks down the stolen
star destroyer to quarrel off and the
resistance has to escape team Finn
infiltrates the Jedi Temple to turn on
the beacon and we see various places
around the galaxy we're seeing the
signal
including a cameo from boss to the
bounty hunter from Empire Strikes Back
but somehow the first order cuts off the
signal and heroes have to flee into the
lower levels of course hunt team Rey and
Poe are being pursued by the knife 9 to
reach the planet bonad in a little-known
planet first mentioned in the force
awakens beginner game in the corporate
sector of the outer rim here poe takes
rey to a seer who can pull information
out of her memories he pulls a star
chart from Ray's mind from her visions
with kylo and then the Knights of Ren
show up and fight Rey in a lightsaber
battle she defeats them in this group
leaves bonad in' meanwhile kylo reaches
Rimac or at good fronts tor Vallum who
is a seven thousand year old alien of
unknown origin with a spinal a body an
intense sinewy muscle described as very
Lovecraftian kylo dreams with
Valentina's a nod to the Empire Strikes
Back cave scene where kylo has to
confront and fight Vader and after a
brutal duel kylo losses so Rey using
information from that star chart and
kylo using information from Balam Rey
and kylo end up in mortis now mortis was
shown in the animated series it's an
ethereal realm within the force outside
of any star system maybe outside the
universe it's a realm inhabited by these
sort of Holy Trinity of the star wars
universe the Father the Son and the
daughter the daughter represents peace
and creation the Sun represents death
and destruction and the father keeps the
balance between them in the episode of
the Clone Wars where they showed up
Anakin
obi-wan and ahsoka were brought into
mortis by the father because he believed
Anakin was the chosen one
but Anakin turned him down this led to a
struggle over the dagger of mortis the
results in the deaths of the father and
the Son and the daughter which in a way
restores the balance one older rumor
about the rise of Skywalker's early
projected plots surrounded actor Matt
Smith who was reported to have been cast
in a major role but yeah ended up not
being in the movie and one of more
common theories out there was that Matt
Smith would have been cast as the son of
mortis anyway
in its Trevorrow Connally script Rey and
kylo battle in mortis they're using the
force energy that they can
whole from each other and it's revealed
that kylo killed Rey's parents at the
behest of Snoke and in the end Luke
obi-wan and Yoda appear as force ghosts
to save Ben but they fail because Ben is
extinguished while all this is going on
Leia has asked Lando to organize the
smugglers to fight the first order roses
captured and tortured by the first order
but manages to escape thin r2 in
Threepio start a citizen's uprising on
Coruscant around the first order Citadel
and Leia joins this fight with her
forces resulting in a massive space in
ground battle you know the two front
battle like the Battle of Endor Chewie
pilots the next wing didn't know he
could fit in one it all ends with of
course the resistance defeating the
first order this later also notes that
Han Solo appeared somewhere in the story
and did confront kylo at some point and
at one point there is apparently a
visual of Leia passing a message on to
bb-8 wearing a similar white gown in
hood to recreate the famous image of her
with r2 and a new hope perhaps this was
the closing image of the film we don't
know yes we don't know how much of this
script is legit yes the AV club
confirmed Trevorrow and Connolly's with
an independent source but i do know that
this story sounds pretty interesting it
could have made him really satisfying
episode 9 I loved the elements of the
force ghost Luke hiding kylo the course
I'm for speakin the mortis sequence and
yeah duel of the fates is a better title
right Skywalker
meanwhile the Lovecraftian tour Vallum
Sith master sounds a bit less
interesting to me and in my view I like
that Palpatine was brought back for this
final chapter even if it doesn't totally
make sense because at least it does
elevate the prequels it reframes the
entire saga as the Palpatine saga which
to me celebrates the finest performer of
these films Ian McDiarmid it allows us
to go back to the awesome ruins of the
Death Star that whole duel in sequence
was one of the best things in this
Disney trilogy and I could also see a
reality in which the duel the Bates
version of episode 9 could have gotten
made but then an equal sized contingent
of audiences were equally disappointed
with that so then they would grasp
around online for a rumored JJ Abrams
Chris Terrio script draft that went
unused and then everyone considers that
one to be so much better which version
of episode 90 you prefer this Trevorrow
Connelly script we've been talking about
or the rise of Skywalker we ended up
getting comment down below with your
thoughts and keep it civil I don't know
what it is about this topic but people
tend to lose their minds over it follow
me at EI vos follow new rock stars on
social
and subscribe to new rockstars need to
be sure to hit that notifications button
so you can get all of our Star Wars
related videos and a reminder that new
rockstars offers exclusive bonus monthly
videos to our generous patrons we
recently made a break down to that
Church seen in the Kingsmen a full movie
analysis of the shining the kind of
videos YouTube won't let us release
publicly on this channel because of you
know the mature content of whatnot you
can access all of it so much other bonus
content we're making by supporting us on
patreon and of course thank you to all
of our current patrons thank you for
watching and I guess we now have the
Jarl cut on the hashtag release list
they didn't even shoot this version of
the script but don't worry the releasers
are on it
[Music]